فلا حكموا مقاطعه خرسون الموالي لروسيا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت بالصواريخ جسر
الرابط بين منطقه خرسون وشبه جزيره القرم
بصواريخ ستورم شادو البريطانيه واضاف
الحاكمه ان الطريق الرئيس في المنطقه تعرض
لاضرار وهذه هي المره الاولى التي يتعرض
فيها هذا الجسر للقصف
من دونيتسكي تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
كارمن نجو خضار كارمن اخر التطورات
نعم سفيان هذه بطبيعه الحال اول مره
يستهدف هذا الجسر ولكن هذا الاستهداف يشكل
العنوان للمرحله المقبله من هذه الحرب
المستمره خرسون التي تاخر فيها هذا الهجوم
وهذه المعارك بفعل تفجير
وشبه جزيره القرم التي تم الحديث عنها
كثيرا المعطيات الاوليه التي وردتنا حول
ما جرى عن هذا الاستهداف هو استهداف
بصواريخ حاكم او حتى رئيس القرم قال ان
هناك ضررا الحق بهذا الجسر ولكن هناك
طريقان اخران يمكن للمواطنين ان يسلكوا ان
يسلكوا هذه هذين الطارقين وبطبيعه الحال
يمكن استمرار الحركه وسيجري العمل على
اصلاح الاضرار الاضرار وفق الصور والمقاطع
المصوره ليست كبيره ولكن بطبيعه الحال
توقفت الحركه عند هذا الجسر المعطيات
الاوليه تشير الى ان هذا الامر قد او
الهدف كان منه اعاقه تح وامدادات القوات
الروسيه لناحيه هذه العمليه العسكريه
الممتده من خرسون وزابولوجيا ولوغانس
ودانياسكو هذه المقاطعات الاربعه وايضا
ضمان شبه جزيره القرم وايضا القراءه
الاوليه تقول ان ما جرى اليوم هو اعاده
عنوان شبه جزيره القرم الذي تكثف في
الايام الماضيه
السلطات الاوكرانيه والقوات الاوكرانيه
تتحدث كثيرا عن شبه جزيره القرم وانها
تصبو للوصول الى هذه المنطقه ولكن هذا
الامر رد عليه قبل ايام وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيو الذي قال ان استهداف شبه
جزيره القرم والاراضي الروسيه لان روسيا
ضمت شبه جزيره القرم عام 2014 وهي جزء لا
يتجزء منها وفق رؤيتها فقال ان اي استهداف
لهذه المنطقه بصواريخ ستون شادو او هايمرز
يعني انخراط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ويعني انخراط ايضا بريطانيا في هذه الحرب
اذا هذا التطور النوعي وهذا الاستهداف له
تبعات بطبيعه الحال في المرحله المقبله
خاصه انه يتم الحديث عن الجزء الثاني من
الهجوم المضاد واذا ما قطعنا كل هذه
المعطيات والتصريحات السياسيه اكان من قبل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير الذي قال ان
الجبهات هدات في المرحله المقبله وهذه
المعطيات الميدانيه نرى ان الايام المقبله
سيكون فيها تطورات كبيره ولكن ايضا هذا
القصف لهذا الجسر يمكن ربطه ايضا بقصف
ثلاث جسور يتصل تصل اركان المقاطعات
الاربعه التي ضمتها روسيا الى اوكرانيا
بيشبه جزيره القرمز اذا شبه جزيره القرم
سفيان ستكون اساسا في المرحله المقبله وفي
عنوان في العنوان الميداني شكرا لك